hi everyone and welcome to house of
horrors I'm serene I'm Dan yes thank you
Dan Fillion today for Jess who is away
sick unfortunately so the show must go
on however so today we picked a game
that's been suggested a couple of times
most recently and fits in coincidentally
without retro game video game history
month which is Dino Crisis which was
released for the original PlayStation
it's good normal Wow wow that was a
dinosaur just in case you didn't know
you're playing a dino game oh my god
nineties Internet dinosaurs are involved
as is a crisis to cure dr. Kirk and
repatriate him what does that mean I
don't know it sounds hard
I don't ever remember their not being a
drastic park his hair is perfect after
pulling that balaclava off so it's
dramatic it's very evil
which makes sense cuz Mikami directed
this game that's disgusting
oh man do you have to kill that we're
gonna die we're gonna die very soon I
don't even know what the street button
is Oh God you should save this is even
scarier than it was here I just wanna
see you panic again Oh get up get up get
up get up get up
Oh 180 turn around I spend the majority
of the game not killing dices but
running from them that sounds like a
terrible idea for a game
where are you ready there yeah okay
can I open doors like in no I got it job
still the needs opened I sprinted
forward
wait wait wait it's looked oh no it's on
top of me oh I'm getting eviscerated oh
okay
she's limping now she did so now she's
the mid pack oh [ __ ] well you have the
laser things that's okay
until ha ha ha ha ha joke's on you
oh whoa just saying probably [ __ ] ah I'm
so glad that wasn't locked
no no subpoena hey your DDK oh wow okay
good job
relax a bit kick up your feet oh okay
lounge was a bad idea
this is not allowed [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh
we find each other each other oh my god
there's so many prices is it dead yet no
I'm nearly like yeah it's dead okay oh
my god we kill the wraps up oh my god
it's a person what Oh a new stuff okay
maybe that's the disc for the thing yes
shotgun
I quit the shotgun basically it's a blow
if then I think you subtracts the key
from the top so it'll be head head yeah
it's something else completely it's if
you flipped the text upside down it
becomes numbers like boobies on a
calculator yes number seeker with some
paper oh my god let's get old let's get
a grid paper out okay wait okay what are
you doing that don't look like okay now
turn your hand upside down zero three
seven seven zero five three yes oh my
god
it was either blow okay I think you need
to start rubbing
you see that's gonna oh wait really
that wasn't a reaction yeah well run run
oh my god attending
run the other Hey sorry she's still not
dead Oh what Watson she's so dead Oh
evening in a dead cutscene where do you
come from ah so close oh okay Edison we
had even resuscitate yourself when
you're unconscious it says you have used
with magic you're bleeding again get up
get up get up get up get up go to the
dog go with the dog come on yeah someone
saying dangers dangers oh it didn't wake
up oh did you just dot it oh you did
good talk
yep yep yep yep just a theory
you don't mean my theories huh oh my god
it's right in front of him
what what oh oh come on what am I meant
oh my god are you serious
come on get up get up lady drag me I'm
pressing all the buttons hippo please
here we go all right this is it this is
the run all right all right what are the
controls again Square to sprint x2 hit
open doors right oh it's in the way it's
physically in your lips lips first that
one okay never mind very the very start
you get out of here really okay oh my
god they always put you in damn corners
seriously
oh okay house Danger Danger Danger
QuickTime event well there really a
quick time I don't know oh my goodness
doesn't mean he's fought through those
two for good that would be a race run so
worth killing that one I didn't think
anyway oh do you think if you sneak past
them don't work so should we try the
elevator ID card oh she could sneak past
these dudes but that could also be a bad
idea you're ballsy let's do it
please be unlocked oh thank goodness
ah that looks [ __ ]
ah Danger Danger Danger
oh geez oh man how she still live up to
all this
Oh Shawn Frank thank you to everyone who
joined us that was Dyna crisis on the
PSN well done that was one hell of a
crisis
thank you for joining us stay on the
stream as I'm filling in for Jessi
Woolworths both of us will be back in
next week same time same day for bars as
usual let us know what you thought about
the stream and if you want us to play
any other retro games since May is video
game history month so we'll be featuring
older games on house for us this month
and as usual thanks for tuning in
tweet at us do the Twitter thingies and
we'll see you later
bye everyone